- On this episode, India
turns into junk, I mean Dunk.
(laughter)
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Because I did Wine Library TV
last I don't remember the intro.
- Hey everybody, this is Gary
Vaynerchuk and this episode 224.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 224 of The
#AskGaryVee Show, okay got it?
(laughter)
Jesus, ready?
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 224 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Ty, I want to keep, I want you
to keep that little thing we
just and right before the show.
That's right I am that rusty
that I couldn't even remember
how to intro this show.
We've been on a major hiatus.
In general, I feel like we made
the switch from DeMeo to Tyler
on the assistant front, Tyler
hasn't prioritized this show as
much as we've needed, Dunk,
so hopefully we'll get
back into great rhythm.
One of the, maybe this is the
third or fourth
show in the new office.
That makes me happy.
India has transformed into a
good-looking, young,
Swedish boy.
- Yep.
- Dunk, tell 'em who
you are real quick?
- Vayner Nation my name is
Eliot Robinson otherwise
known as Dunk.
I'm 18-years-old, I'm from
Sweden and I'm the co-host for
The #AskGaryVee Show today.
- [Gary] Very cool.
Dunk and I interacted on
Snapchat and Instagram where he
did some great work
under his Dunk account.
I met him for five minutes,
he flew from Sweden to London
when I was there.
I sat with him for
5-10 minutes and I said,
"I need this kid
to work with me in
"the United States of America."
- Mhmmm.
- And that was even before that
I knew that you didn't need
all sorts of legal paper.
That's how committed I was.
Whatever these overheads are
I'm gonna cover them because
I believe in you so much and by
the way he has made an impact.
Even AJ who's really tough,
I think, I'm very optimistic,
I think everybody's
really talented.
AJ's like, "What's up
with this Dunk kid?"
I'm like, "Alright,
VaynerSports, relax."
Alright, let's do it Dunk.
Now listen, for all the great
things that you bring I do not
think you are
gonna do this well.
I have a feeling that you're not
gonna do a good job but let's
see how it plays out.
- Hey, I think I'm
charismatic but we'll see.
- I know your charismatic.
- First question.
- Yes.
- My friend and I are both
digital marketers with very
credible experiences--
- Well, you've
already screwed up.
You're supposed to
say the person's name.
(laughter)
- And it says
anonymous, that's why.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
- Interesting.
Okay, keep going.
- [Voiceover] "My friend and
I recently started working
"for an app startup.
"The person who manages digital
marketing is inexperienced and,
"in our opinion,
stunting potential growth.
"We are looking for an
opportunity to show our talent
"to execs without
overstepping our boundaries.
"How can we show that we are
"better for the
role to the execs?"
- I feel this is actually your
question and you don't believe
in Andy and this is not real.
This is more you projecting your
opinions about
what's going on here.
- And that's why it's anonymous.
- Yes.
(laughter)
Yeah, listen, I think much
like what goes on here and this
is why it's funny and
this is for the whole team.
I think we've got
a good situation
so many of you don't.
My advice here is what
I do think we create more of.
You know what's funny?
I create a company where you can
start hacking and doing things
you know that you can do that
but it's your own trying to be
nice to whomever that may hurt
that's supposed to be doing it
that holds it back.
So this is a really fascinating
thing at VaynerMedia.
I've created a world where
I never want people to not show,
if you can show it, you know,
then you can
do it then just do it.
Show that person.
Now the tough
part of that advice is,
let me give you
a great scenario.
In this exact scenario where
there's a lot of people on my
team that are talented and
everybody's got different roles
and a lot of your mishmoshed
into different responsibilities.
Some that aren't even their best
skill set versus other things
that other people are doing,
they start liking each other.
My team in general, I mean, they
don't all have to be the best of
best friends but you guys
genuinely like each other and so
what's really holding it back is
not hurting that other person's
feelings of, "Why are you
going into my territory?"
It's very complicated.
I mean look, here's part of
this, this is much like life
it's just a
black-and-white answer.
Either you step and run through
the china shop and show your
skills and take the risk of
saying here and by the way
there's a good way
and a bad way to do it.
My real answer would be go to
the person that is doing that
role and saying, "I really
believe in myself in this craft.
"I know this is your role I know
I'm in accounting and you're the
"creative director but
can you help me show you
"or give me the air cover to
show Gary that I can do this
"because here's how
it's gonna play out.
"Either that's what's gonna
happen or I'm gonna quit and
"leave here and go do it
somewhere else and I want to us
"to be teammates
not adversaries."
Now, eight is a big number,
8 out of 10 times that person is
gonna try to hold
down the other person.
Out of insecurity, fear, all
these things but you might get
lucky and it might be one
of those 2 out of 10 times.
That's my favorite way to do it
because I think that's the only
middle step to the black and
white thing which is to answer
the question show somebody.
- Yeah.
- Like edit an episode of
DailyVee and be like,
"Told you, Other Tyler,
I'm better than you."
Just do it.
Or don't and be miserable
and let a little kernel of
negativity eventually become
cancer and it's gonna end up
with you underperforming,
getting fired or you quitting.
That's the
punchline of all of this.
All the things I talk about to
not suppress are predicated on
the outcome's gonna
be the outcome anyway.
So why not just speed
it up but with humility.
So like I get away with a lot
of stuff because I get to the
punchline but I coat it with as
much honey and humility so that
it becomes swallow-able.
Consumable would have
been a better way to go.
- Cool.
Next video question from Jan.
- Jan.
- I wanna ask because you don't
do it often but from time to
time you mention China WeChat,
the other internet
and stuff like that.
So do you actually spend time
on studying these things,
how they work,
how they're different and
if so what do you focus on and
have you learned something
already that you're applying in
your business or that you are
sharing with the clients in the
US and all around the world?
So thank you very
much for the grind.
Thank you very much for
answering my question
and have
a great day. Bye.
- Jan, great question and I'm
really dying to see if you guys,
I feel like you guys are
being very smart and
asked that question.
Something very funny happened
two days ago, yesterday?
Yesterday, right?
Yesterday I sent a team
wide email about this?
Was that yesterday
or two days ago?
- [DRock] Yesterday.
- Yesterday.
Yesterday, I sent an email to my
entire teams and it said China,
it's time.
Let's start
transcribing my content.
It's time to get serious,
Jan, so the answer is the other
internet, China is something
I'm very, very passionate and a
believer up on a religious level
but I've never gone to church.
Meaning I know it's right.
I know it's big.
I know the biggest consumer set
in the world is there but you
can't get to everything and much
like there's a lot of things
I'm not doing well
even within the US,
I've not been able to
open up a can of worms.
VaynerMedia eventually's
gonna play in that market.
It will have to do as we're
becoming global leader and so no
question the thing I'm
most disappointed about on a
microlevel in my career over the
last 36 months is that I haven't
forced myself to spend four or
five separate trips in China.
Taste it, get used to it
and really articulate
a real strategy.
Literally, literally I became
so fed up with myself that
yesterday I sent to the team
it's time for me to become a
player in that market and so I'm
sure that's why the question was
asked or maybe it's just
serendipitous but the answer is
no I have not spent time
analyzing the WeChats,
TenCents and the rest the
market but it is something
I better get around to
if I have to expand
on the aspirations that I have.
I think both VaynerMedia and
me as a brand have enormous
opportunities
within that market.
I think we fit the mold on an
entrepreneurial level and so
I'm excited about
the next frontier.
- Cool.
Next is a video
question from Diogo Silva.
- Hey Gary, I'm Diogo from
Portugal and I have a very
simple question to ask you.
Are you good with names?
Are you able to remember every
single employer and people you
do business with names'?
And how important is that
skill for your business?
Thank you Gary for
answering my question--
- This episode, I feel like
this episode, you know what?
I feel like since we haven't had
a lot of time that there's been
a whole lot of work, I'm
very intrigued by this episode.
I am terrible with names.
It's devastating.
I have so much pride
and I know that
people that watch DailyVee
are probably surprised by how
many names I know but there are
so many names I don't know.
And I don't know names of
like 18 months in clients.
I don't know names of like
people, it's unbelievable how
much context I know
but names I don't.
Meaning there's employees here
that I don't like things that
are going on with like the
well-being of their relationship
because I follow them on social
and follow their boyfriend and
then figure out about you like
literally, literally like and
definitely know their
performance and remember that
they had a bad day or recall
this or just deep, deep, deep
stuff but I'm like is
that Karen or is it Susan?
It's super tough for me.
It's something I'm very bad
at and it's very important.
People like,
here's what I think,
tactically it's important
and people would be disappointed
if they've been paying
VaynerMedia for two years and
they're an important client and
I don't know their name.
I understand that.
What overrides that while I feel
great is that's the tactic to
the thing that matters which
is knowing one's name is one
version of caring
about that person.
I know how much I care and
though I hate that the easiest
version of that is not something
I have a skill for, it's all the
other stuff that I have
skills for that make up for that
vulnerability because that is a
surface level vulnerability,
not a deep vulnerability.
And so, I think at a macro level
it is stunningly unimportant.
What it perceives to mean is
the most important thing
but tactically I don't think so.
On a micro level,
sure, it's important.
You like that answer?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Question--
- I like this kid.
- from Ryan.
- Hey Gary. I'm Ryan.
In a video with Joe Polish you
said that you can sell rocks on
the street and still
make 100 grand a year.
Is that true?
If so, would you make a video
where you sell a rock to someone
who doesn't know you?
Thanks.
- So Ryan theoretically,
it is true.
Practically, listen
the truth is,
actually I'm surprised
I'm answering this.
I think I can make 100,000.
I wish I was at a point in my
life where I could be so crazy
and right now off
of this, do it.
Go with DRock to some crazy
place where nobody knows who
I am which, oh, by the way
and I love you all for this,
which is almost everywhere.
Like down the street but you
know, go to a place where
I'm not me and
I know that, trust me,
you guys perceive
me bigger than I am.
I'm just me and I think, now
look, here's what I would do.
I'd go to place, first, I'd go
to a rich upper-middle-class
area where it's not too rich
but upper-middle-class demo and
I would set up shop on the
corner of the street and
I guess most of my day would be,
and it'd have to have
rocks in the general area.
Access to rocks--
- Hmmm.
- No, no I'll tell you why.
I understand but like if
I'm trying to make 100,000
and I can pick anywhere
like you might as
well if there's
a perfect ZIP Code
where it's got the right
income level that I want and
there's access to it efficiency
but I know I can buy 'em on the
internet and all that stuff but
nonetheless I guess I would try
to market myself as somebody who
is creative on top of a rock.
So I don't think I would if
I was selling rock I wouldn't
try to sell you a rock 'cause
that wouldn't work but what
I would do is I would doodle
and create on top of rocks
and try to sell them.
And I genuinely with my entire
heart believe that I can make a
$100,000 a year
in year two, firm.
In year 1, I would make
$36,000 in profit.
- Could.
I believe it's possible
to sell just a rock.
- It is but I think what I would
do because I'd want to get
100,000 is the doodling on top
would then constitute as art and
that becomes agnostic and then
marketing can take over and then
all I need to do is have
Leonardo DiCaprio take a picture
on his Instagram that he's
bought this rock 'cause it's art
and then it's game over.
It's just high school
arbitrage, all of it is.
- Alright, next
question is from Betty Liu--
- Oh, Betty!
- Yep.
- Awesome.
- So Gary, you're so successful.
You run a $100 million
revenue company.
How do you stay hungry?
- Period.
Betty, I think that truth is
I think a lot of
us are hardwired.
I think because
I didn't come from much,
because I didn't
speak the language,
because I wasn't
physically large.
I actually think that's
a dude thing for sure.
And because I think I'm
wired to love underdogs.
I've always loved them.
I think where I've come from,
there is no I've never made it.
First of all, I don't
like the physical things.
That's a huge advantage.
Not needing to buy a plane
or an $8000 pair sneakers.
There's no
physical thing I want.
Just like the awesome Instagram
photo that Tyler you put
together of the game
(bell chimes)
I love the process.
I'm hungry forever.
I'm the hungriest.
I'm super hungry.
I threw up this morning and I'm
theoretically physically I'm not
hungry right now 'cause I'm
feeling a little woozy but
emotionally as an
entrepreneur, I'm the hungriest.
It's incredible.
I'm dramatically more successful
than I was 10 years ago,
I'm more hungry not less.
- Because?
- Because I just think it
was hardwired from the get.
'Cause I just think
it's black and white.
I just think at some level
you're just wired
the way you are.
There is nothing that's gonna
fill my appetite because what
drives my hunger is the process
not the results and then by
nature in that
construct it goes forever.
The only thing that changes my
hunger is if is if the two other
most important variables in this
game play themselves out:
the health and well-being of my
family or the way I feel about
the allocation of my time and
the depth of that
time with my family.
Those are the only
vulnerabilities.
There's no $14 million check
or $48 billion check
or buying the Jets.
There's nothing
that will stop the hunger.
When I put my jersey on, when
I'm in the context of being a
businessman, the hungry
vibe will be there forever.
It's when I'm Gary as a person
where there's other things in my
life besides being on the field
that could play out that could
get me to be less
hungry professionally.
But on the field, I'm going to
be a psycho through
and through forever.
- Like it.
- That's it.
Great, it's a good show.
Did a good job, Junk.
I like you asking--
- Junk?
(laughter)
- Listen, I was just
proud I said episode clean.
I messed that it up
the last four times.
I messed it up the
last four times.
Question of the day: Tell me
about the end of your summer.
I've got a lot of flights coming
up and I feel a little out of
touch because we haven't
done this in a little while,
Vayner Nation so this will be
a good way for me to just get a
sense for 3 to 400 of you that
I've really, it's funny you guys
are fans of my work
and I appreciate that.
You'd be shocked how much I'm a
fan of your feedback to my work
and who mixes it up and who like
tries to say like rogue stuff on
purpose to game the system and
who's totally into
it now but fades off.
Who's always into
who comes in and out.
It's amazing on
how much I know
about you even if
I don't know your name.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)